why did you write lost fair
well i co-wrote last fair um
i actually found um
a story on virtual pitchfest which is a
i'm a producer member of that it's an
online thing where people pitch
to me the producer so
they they'll look through the people
that they can pitch to
and they'll kind of pick different
people if they like their resumes or
they like what they've done in the past
and they'll choose you specifically to
pitch their project to
and then you read the one page pitch and
if you like it you you you go ahead and
read the screenplay
so uh it's a it's a good project for
writers virtual pitch fest
very good um so i
found the project there and i had been
looking
for something that i thought that i
could produce
um at a price
um and even though it had
kids in it and it was kind of a road
movie
and um there were
there were things that i i mean
first of all i just i loved the the
premise i loved the characters
and i loved some of the dialogue
but it wasn't really in a full
screenplay form
for instance the main bad guy in the
movie he was talked about
in the original script but he wasn't a
character in the movie
so there were certain formal things
and structural things that needed to be
done to the script
so that's why i got involved writing
with
rachel ray who originally pitched me on
the project
when you found the pitch on virtual
pitch fest what was it that stood out to
you
not the first time i've been asked that
question and it's
it's very hard to say i
you know it spoke to me and i think
that's the greatest reason to make a
movie is when when something really
speaks to you
and it was about this 11 year old girl
and who had muscular dystrophy
so she was crippled um
and she was not expected to live
more than a year or so during the time
that the movie was made
and she had been sold by her mother
and um so it was a very dark story but
it also had
uh very kind of metaphysical elements
in the story so it was you know
um i've been meditating and and
and studying western uh
esoteric philosophy for for many years
and
there's a thing about you know people
think oh i've got to reach higher
consciousness
but i don't if that's not enough you've
got to
spherically expand your consciousness so
you you're reaching down into the depths
as much as you're reaching for the
height
and and and the breadth of it and so
spiritually um
this movie was very dark and and very
light at the same time
and i think it was
uh i think it was elements of that that
i saw in the initial pitch
that really attracted me to it
so you contacted rachel or through the
website you can't through
through the website i contacted
rachel and she she sent me the script
and then
somehow she
she got my contact information off the
web
which is not hard to do but um so she
she started calling me and she just like
she ravaged me with phone calls and all
right you know
so um i thought gosh
so she was very tenacious and
um i said well the chances of us getting
this
made as a movie you know are like you
know 100 to one
because that's the way the movies are
you know so um
you prepared to go on that journey with
me and she was
and so together we started whipping the
uh whipping the script into shape and
developing
characters and making it a makeable
movie and um
the next problem that i had was that i
had an 11 year old
that was in every scene of a movie
that needed to carry the movie so
i decided that i wasn't going to make
the movie
unless i found that 11 year old girl
so um i found alexis rosinski
and she is an amazing little
actress not so little anymore she time
goes by
and once i found her then i decided to
green light the movie and i was in a
position to green light the movie
because i was financing the movie
which is breaking the golden rule of
cinema which is never use your own money
but i loved the project so much and i
was so into it that
i decided to do that and rachel
the writer that you co-wrote it with is
she based in l.a
no and i never met rachel until
sometime after the movie so we wrote
together remotely
and she's in a
in a wheelchair and she lives in
victoria columbia
and i had a very nice visit with her
a few months ago i went up to visit her
and
got to meet her for the first time but
it's basically the story of her the true
story of her childhood so
it was pretty emotional you know to meet
her
ah so hence why she was so tenacious
about it
yes and um it was funny because she had
followed my career
she said well while her and her brother
were being
uh you know abused by her parents her
escape was into the movies
and so she knew of me through those
early credits and uh
it was weird and and
not only that when she made the pitch
she made a mistake she wasn't originally
going to pitch it to me she was going to
pitch it
because she didn't think it was my cup
of tea so she was gonna
pitch it to somebody else so the pitch
came to me
uh without her really uh targeting me so
i guess it was meant to happen you know
you